♪♪
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS ARE WETTING
THEIR PANTS OVER THE MID-TERMS.
HOT MIC JUST CAUGHT CHUCK
SCHUMER ADMITTING THINGS ARE
GOING DOWNHILL.
THEY HAVE THEMSELVES TO BLAME IF
THEY LOSE BIG AND GERALDO WILL
HAVE TO FORK OVER $1,000.
MY DAD DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
CLASSY --
>> Geraldo: THE WINNER WOULD
DONATE --
>> Jesse: WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT
LATER.
POLITCO IS HIGHLIGHTING THE
GROWING PANIC.
DEMOCRATS DEBATE THEMSELVES.
WHY DO WE SUCK?
I ASKED MYSELF THAT QUESTION
SOMETIMES.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
FORMER TOP RESPONSSPIN ARTIST JI
HAS MORE.
>> PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
THESE RACES.
THERE'S ENCOURAGING SIGNS LIKE
RECORDERLY VOTING.
NUMBERS THE HOUSE RACES ARE NOT
WHERE THEY SHOULD BE.
IT'S A REFLECTION OF THE FACT
THAT DEMOCRATS ARE KIND OF
WORRIED ABOUT WHERE THIS IS
GOING RIGHT NOW.
IT'S FELT WORSE OVER THE LAST
WEEK OR SO.
>> Jesse: IT'S NO WONDER THE
DEMOCRATS ARE BANKING ON BARACK
OBAMA TO BAIL THEM OUT.
HE'S IN BATTLEGROUND, GEORGIA.
JOE BIDEN IS NOW STRAIGHT UP
LYING ABOUT GAS PRICES.
>> WE'RE DOWN $1.25 FROM THIS
SUMMER AND THEY'VE BEEN FALLING
THE LAST THREE WEEKS AS WELL.
THAT ENDS UP FOR SAVINGS FOR
FAMILIES.
TODAY THE MOST COMMON PRICE OF
GAS IN AMERICA IS $3.39.
DOWN FROM OVER $5 WHEN I TOOK
OFFICE.
>> Jesse: GERALDO, ARE YOU
HAVING REGRETS ABOUT OUR BIG
BET?
>> Geraldo: WHAT I WAS THINKING,
WHAT IF GEORGIA DOES THE SAME
THING IT DID LAST TIME AND YOU
DON'T KNOW WHO WON BECAUSE
NOBODY GETS 50%?
THEN IT'S ANOTHER MONTH?
IMAGINE THIS AGONY BEING
PROLONGED AS IN GEORGIA'S
SPECIAL ELECTION --
>> Jesse: REPUBLICANS MIGHT NOT
NEED GEORGIA AT THIS POINT.
>> Geraldo: I STILL BELIEVE
OBVIOUSLY THAT THE REPUBLICANS
WILL PREVAIL IN THE HOUSE.
WE'LL HAVE DIVIDED GOVERNMENT.
I BELIEVE THAT'S WHY THE DOW IS
MARCHING ON.
BECAUSE WHAT INVESTORS LIKE
DIVIDED GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
DIVIDED GOVERNMENT CAN'T SPEND
MONEY THE WAY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DID ON 26 VOTES.
>> Jesse: KENNEDY, WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THE MID-TERMS?
>> Kennedy: GERALDO IS RIGHT
ABOUT THAT.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING WATCHING
THIS MOMENTUM SHIFT SO QUICKLY
SO CLOSE TO THE MID-TERMS.
BECAUSE EVEN A WEEK OR TWO WEEKS
AGO, DEMOCRATS WERE INCREDIBLY
CONFIDENT ABOUT THE MOMENTUM
THAT THEY HAD DEVELOPED FROM
AUGUST ONWARD.
AND YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT CAN
LIE ABOUT GAS PRICES.
HE CAN SAY, WELL, INFLATION
ISN'T THE WORST IT'S EVER BEEN
SO IT'S NOT BAD.
PEOPLE KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
PEOPLE KNOW THEY'RE PAYING TOO
MUCH FOR GAS, PAYING TOO MUCH
FOR EGGS AND MILK AND BREAD AND
GROUND BEEF AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
THEY DON'T LIKE BEING LIED TO.
SO THEIR THINKING IS, THIS IS
YOUR SYSTEM AND YOU'RE CAUSING
ME PAIN.
I WANT TO BE OUT OF PAIN.
BIDEN IS SAYING REPUBLICANS WILL
RUIN THE ECONOMY BUT HE'S NOT
SAYING HOW.
HE'S NOT SAYING WHAT IMPLICIT
LIT ABOUT REPUBLICANISM THAT
WILL DESTROY THE ECONOMY?
SO I THINK PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
GAMBLE AND DO WHATEVER THEY CAN
TO GET OUT OF PAIN.
>> Jesse: MARTHA, WHEN HE SAID
HE CAME IN AND GAS WAS $5 A
GALLON, YOU THINK HE'S STRAIGHT
UP LYING OR HE DOESN'T REMEMBER?
>> Martha: I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
THIS IS NOT OPINION.
THIS IS FACT.
YOU CAN EASILY LOOK IT UP WHERE
GAS PRICES WERE, 3 SOMETHING AND
WENT TO $5 OR SIX IN SOME PLACES
IN CALIFORNIA, CLOSE TO SEVEN.
THE OTHER THING IS, INFLATION
THAT HE TALKED ABOUT INHERITING
WAS AT 1.4%.
NOW IT'S 8.2%.
IT'S VERY EASY TO PULL UP THIS
CHART AND LOOK AT IT.
WE'RE IN FAR WORSE SHAPE IN THE
ECONOMY THAN WE WERE WHEN THE
PRESIDENT TOOK OFFICE.
THAT'S NOT MY OPINION.
THAT'S LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS.
A RECESSION IS TWO NEGATIVE
PERIODS OF GROWTH.
WE HAD THIS.
THEN WE HAD A REDEFINITION OF
WHAT A RECESSION IS.
IT KIND OF WORKED.
PEOPLE ARE STILL SAYING, LET'S
SEE IF WE'RE GOING TO BE IN A
RECESSION.
WE'VE HEARD FROM EVERY LEADER ON
WALL STREET PRETTY MUCH THAT
2023 LOOKS VERY ROUGH.
THE GDP NUMBER WAS OKAY.
IT WASN'T GREAT WHEN YOU PEEL
AWAY THE TOP LINE NUMBER.
HE CAN -- ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
WITH THE PRESIDENT IS HE HASN'T
MET PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE AND
WHERE THEY'RE LIVING.
LIKE KENNEDY IS SAYING.
YOU CAN'T JUST KEEP TELLING
PEOPLE THINGS ARE ROSY AND FINE.
PEOPLE GO WAIT, HOLD ON.
IT'S NOT.
SPEAK TO ME LIKE I'M AN ADULT
AND I KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
I MIGHT WANT TO GIVE YOU ANOTHER
CHANCE.
BUT YOU CAN'T TELL PEOPLE THAT
THEY'RE NOT EXPERIENCING WHAT
THEY'RE EXPERIENCING.
>> Jesse: I'M ALMOST CURIOUS
WHAT BARACK OBAMA WILL SAY WHEN
HE GOES TO THESE SAME STATES.
HE'S GOT TO SAY SOMETHING
DIFFERENCE THAN WHAT JOE BIDEN
IS SAYING.
>> Tyrus: HE'S GOING TO SAY HEY,
WE HAVE TO STOP ACT AGO FOOL AND
STOP LISTENING.
BUT OBAMA COULDN'T SAVE HIM.
IF HE WAS RUNNING HIMSELF.
NUMBER 1, LET'S BREAK IT DOWN.
YOU DON'T BRAG ABOUT HOW YOU
LOVE GASOLINE CARS AND YOU DON'T
LIKE CARS AND TELL US ALL WE
NEED -- OUR PRESIDENT IS SO OUT
OF TOUCH.
IF YOU CAN'T REMEMBER THE PRICE
OF GAS WHEN YOU'RE DOING A
SPEECH ABOUT THE PRICE OF GAS,
YOU ARE UNFIT FOR OFFICE,
PERIOD.
POINT BLANK.
IF I CAME ON HERE AND MY SUBJECT
WAS CRIME AND I STARTED TO
TALKING ABOUT MY SCORE ON X BOX,
THERE WOULD BE STUFF GOING ON
DURING THE COMMERCIAL.
I WOULD HAVE TO LEAVE.
FINALLY, WASN'T NO HOT MIC
MOMENT.
SCHUMER POSITIONED IT JUST RIGHT
SO YOU GOT HIS GOOD SIDE AND YOU
COULDN'T SEE BIDEN'S FACIAL
EXPRESSION OF HUH?
HE JUST LEANED IN AND SAID --
EVEN WHEN HE SAID IS OH, IT
DIDN'T HURT THAT BAD.
WE'RE STILL GOING TO BE GOOD.
EVERYBODY STICKS TOGETHER.
IF EVERYBODY VOTES THE PARTY
LINE, WE'LL BE FINE.
OH, HOT MIC.
DID I SAY THAT?
HOT MIC MOMENT.
I KNOW A LITTLE SOMETHING ABOUT
SIMULATED COMBAT AND MESSING
WITH AN INTERVIEW TO LOOK
SERIOUS, THIS IS NOT RESTLING.
THIS IS OUR LIVES AND IT'S JUST
A SHAM.
HOPEFULLY THE VOTERS ARE SEEING
IT'S